we're told the double number line shows
that five pounds of avocados costs $9
and so what is going on here with this
double number line
this shows how as we increase the number
of avocados how the cost increases so
for example when we have zero pounds of
avocados it costs us zero dollars when
we have five pounds of avocados it costs
us nine dollars and so if you look at
any point over here let's say you look
right over here this would be let's see
this is one right this is one two three
four five if you look at one this point
on the cost number line would tell you
how much one pound of avocado would cost
two pounds of avocados how much would
that cost you would look at this second
number line right over there so they ask
us based on the ratio shown in the
doubler based on the ratio shown in the
double number line what is the cost for
one pound of avocados so pause the video
and think about it remember one pound of
avocados on this top number line we look
at the second number line the cost would
be right over here what is this going to
be well we could just set it up as a
ratio the ratio of pounds of avocados to
cost is going to be let me do this in
some colors so if I have five pounds of
avocados it is going to cost me nine
dollars so the ratio of pounds to
dollars is five to nine so if I were to
have one pound of avocado one pound of
avocado I have divided by five to get 1
pound of avocado I would have to do the
same thing for the cost so if I divide 9
by 5 this is going to be nine fifths
dollars of nine fifths dollars would be
the cost of one pound
well nine fist isn't always the most
natural way to write money so you could
view this nine fifths is equal to one
and 4/5 which is equal to one and eight
tenths which is equal to one point eight
or you could say this is one dollar and
80 cents
so if you were to go on to this double
number line the cost of 1 pound of
avocado this point right over here would
be one dollar and 80 cents if you said 2
pounds of avocados well now you would
double it so this would be three dollars
and 60 cents and you would go on and on
and on all the way until you got to nine
dollars here let's do another example so
here we are told the double number line
shows how many model trains
Eirene can build in a week so we can see
in zero weeks you can't build any trains
but and then one week she can build nine
trains and they ask us which table
represents the rate of Irene building
model trains so pause this video and see
if you can figure it out
so once again every week she can build
nine trains so one way to think about it
is the ratio of week two trains would be
one to nine so let's see if I look at
this table I just want to see where the
ratio between weeks two trains stays at
one to nine so five to forty five that
is still one two nine to go from one to
five I've multiplied by five and then to
go to nine to 45 I've also multiplied by
five so this one checks out now and
another way to think about it is 45 is 9
times five so nine times and not that
might be easy way to think about it over
here 12 to 108
well that's once again 12 times nine is
108 and then 26 to 234 let's see 26
times 10 would be 260 minus 26 yeah it
would be 234 so this is nine times so in
all of these cases the ratio of trains
or the ratio of weeks to trains is one
to nine so this one is looking good so
I'll just circle that in but let's just
make sure that this one doesn't work
well over here the ratio of weeks to
trains is 9 to 1 not 1 to 9 the train
should be 9 times the weeks while here
the weeks is 9 times the train so just
looking at that first one we know that
this is not going to work
out let's do one last example the number
the double number line shows how many
snowballs Jacob and his friends can make
in one minute in no minutes they can
make zero snowballs in one minute they
can make 12 complete the table to show
the same information as the double
number line so once again pause this
video and see if you can work this out
well we can think about it as a ratio
the ratio of minutes to snowballs is one
to twelve so minutes to snowballs is one
to twelve or another way to think about
it is the snowballs is going to be
twelve times the minutes and so over
here if I have twelve snowballs well we
already know that's going to be one
minute if I have forty-eight snowballs
well let's just think about it to go
from 12 to 48 you have to multiply by
four see if four times as many snowballs
is gonna take you four times as many
minutes and then if you go to five well
to go from one to five you multiply by
five so you're gonna have five times as
many snowballs then you would be able to
make in one minute so five times 12 is
60 and we're done it could be one to
twelve four to forty eight five to 64
every five minutes you can make sixty
snowballs or they make sixty snowballs